punk-ass she is celebrated like a
rockstar
Helen Pankhurst great-granddaughter of
Emmeline Pankhurst one of Britain's most
eminent campaigners for women's rights
at a women's march from London's
Trafalgar Square to be speaking here on
the exact same platform used by my
grandmother Sylvia and my
great-grandmother Emmeline during those
very very difficult suffragette campaign
feels incredibly surreal people have
always asked Helen Pankhurst about her
name and as a consequence she got
involved with feminism from a young age
she now writes books and uses her famous
name to raise awareness of the battles
that still need to be fought as as you
put the sash on it's that engagement
with the past same words still relevant
today and you feel quite energised
over 100 years ago Helen's family
sometimes used militant tactics to fight
for women's right to vote they were put
in prison and went on hunger strike
today women do have equal rights but for
Helen Pankhurst there are still many in
justices in daily life the overall
misogyny the overall male entitlement at
work home girls putting themselves
backwards the whole pink off' occation
of their space just there's so many ways
in which we still have a major problem
Helen Pankhurst says there is still a
lot of work to do in Parliament itself
that's despite a third of British MPs
being women and there being a female
prime minister Theresa May she often
works with female politicians we're
still in a very male-dominated
atmosphere and we still had I had a
colleague in in previous colleague in
the 2015 setting who was whiffed across
the chamber from by
even pinochle assumes and that came to
behavior still goes on it's a very
adversarial atmosphere at events in
Parliament and also at the women's
marchers Helen Pankhurst stands shoulder
to shoulder with Britain's politicians
and they're listening to her
what we need is feminism without borders
a world where the voices of the poorest
women count as much as that of the
richest men the rallying calls of old
are just as good as ever
deeds not words deeds not words
[Applause]